me han enviado este problema de
integrales definidas y me pareció tan
bueno como todos los demás y yo creo que
para aprender integrales definidas y
aprender en general en matemáticas es
muy importante hacer muchos ejercicios
el ejercicio dice toma la integral de pi
medios up y de la función menos coseno
cuadrado de x al menos pues el cuadrado
lo voy a multiplicar por el seno de x y
todo esto de x bueno antes de entrar a
toda la teoría que hay detrás de esta
integral y sustituir los valores de pi y
de pi medios por el teorema fundamental
del cálculo lo primero que dice es
graficar lo tome la función menos coseno
cuadrado de x por seno de x y lo puse en
mi gráfica d'or y aquí está su gráfica
en esta gráfica puede observar voy a
tratar de hacer un poco más grande
porque está muy pequeño esta gráfica
tiene aquí al punto x igual a pi medios
y hasta acá al punto x igual a pib y
recuerden que la integral definida lo
que me da es un área en este caso quiero
el área que se encuentra arriba de mí
y abajo del eje de las equis esta área
negativa que yo tengo aquí por lo tanto
al resolver yo esta integral la función
menos uno por coseno cuadrado de x por
senado de x voy a obtener el área que
hay entre medios y pin entonces como os
voy a resolver esta integral que parece
estar muy complicada la voy a resolver
por sustitución de su cuenta de que aquí
hay dos funciones el coseno cuadrado de
x x el seno de x entonces primero me
pregunto quién es la función que tiene
la potencia o en su dado caso que es la
función más loca de estas dos funciones
y la función más loca es el coste no
cuadrado de x de hecho esto se sostiene
en la derivada de una composición de
funciones por la regla de la cadena que
decía la verdad la cadena si tú quieres
derivar con respecto a x efe compuestas
deje de x pues entonces tomamos la
derivada de f aplicada gdx y esto hay
que multiplicarlo por la derivada de gtx
y bueno si ustedes les confunde mucho
esto no le hagan caso a ésta
en notación que acabo de poner sin
embargo nos puede servir si ustedes si
entienden esta anotación porque fíjense
yo podría decir que quede x es igual
coseno de x y f compuesta deje de x es
el kun seno cuadrado de x y quien es la
derivada del coseno de x pues es el
menos seno de x cuidado tenemos aquí
bueno esto es si lo quieren hacer por la
regla de la cadena yo voy a utilizar la
sustitución por lo tanto voy a hacer un
cambio de variable entonces a ver dónde
puedo poner mi cambio de variable bien
voy a abordar esto vamos a hacer que no
lo vimos y voy a empezar otra vez esta
integral definida la voy a resolver por
sustitución
yo creo que resolverla por sustitución
va a hacer que las cosas sean más claras
para ti y mucho más sencillas por lo
tanto voy a reescribir esta integral
esta integral es lo mismo que la
integral de pi medios api de coseno
cuadrado de x de hecho es déjenme
déjenme spain voy a quitar este cuadrado
aquí lo voy a poner aquí con seno de x
elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo
esto lo voy a multiplicar por el menos
seno de x y todo esto de x y bueno
ustedes van a preguntar en qué casos uso
la integral por sustitución bueno desde
cuenta que la derivada del coste no de x
está aquí que es el menos seno de x
entonces yo pienso en una integral
resuelta por sustitución o por lo
contrario la regla de la cadena cuando
yo tengo la derivada a un lado entonces
voy a usar un cambio de variables o va a
ser igual al coseno dx y ustedes van a
preguntar por qué es el seno de x
bueno pues porque su derivada hasta que
al lado es el menos seno de x por lo
tanto me conviene hacer el cambio de
variable v igualdad por seno de x
derivamos lo la derivada de v con
respecto a x es igual al menos en donde
x que es la derivada del coseno y bueno
ahora si yo multiplico de ambos lados
por de x voy a obtener que de eeuu es
igual al menos seno de x por de x
y darse cuenta que con este cambio de
variables ya hay cosas que se marcan en
nuesta integral desde cuenta que todo
esto de aquí por mi cambio de variable
es lo mismo que de uno y esto de aquí
bueno pues wilco seno de x por lo tanto
con zona de x elevado al cuadrado es lo
mismo que un elevado al cuadrado
esto es cuadrada y bueno ahora para
terminar de resolver esta integral lo
que voy a hacer es cambiar de color otra
vez voy a hacerlo más animado y hay que
hacer un cambio en los límites de
integración porque porque cuando yo
tengo el cambio de variable o igual al
coseno dx entonces para yo escribir todo
en términos de v
hay que hacer que mis límites de
integración coincidan con una lógica de
hacer mi cambio de variable pero es muy
sencillo lo que hay que hacer es si es
igual al seno de x y ese es mi cambio de
variable evaluar mis límites de
integración en coseno de x es decir aquí
va a ser el coseno de medios mi límite
inferior y mi límite superior va a ser
el coste no pero debbie como era mi
límite superior de mi integral original
entonces al hacer el cambio de variable
jose no debí de quien a bueno de
cuadrada y esto por de entonces hay que
multiplicarlo por dv y de en su cuenta
que ya existe la integral al hacer este
cambio de variable la integral día es
muy sencilla porque esto me queda bueno
vamos a hacer los límites de evaluación
océano de ping es ni más ni menos que
menos 1 y cose 9 primeros es 0 de quien
después de un cuadrado de un entonces
voy a ponerlo la integral de 0 a menos 1
de cuadrada de 1 y bueno esto por el
teorema fundamental del cálculo dice
resuelve la integral de eeuu cuadrada y
evaluado en los límites de integración
entonces la integral de un cuadrado es
una integral es muy sencilla es le
sumamos 1 el exponente pública y lo
dividimos entre ese mismo número entre 3
ya esto lo tengo que evaluar entre los
límites de integración que es de 0 a
menos 1 entonces pública entre 3
evaluado de 0 a menos 1
y bueno esta operación ya es una presión
muy sencilla es menos uno elevado al
cubo entre 3 ya esto hay que restarle 0
entre 3 es decir la evaluación en el
límite superior menos la evaluación en
el límite inferior y esto es menos un
tercio y hemos acabado esta integral que
queríamos resolver desde cuenta que si
tenía que salir un área negativa debido
a que mi curva estaba abajo del eje de
las equis y además el área que está
entre el eje de las equis y mi curva con
seno cuadrado de x por menos seno de x
es esta área que yo tengo aquí y al
haber resuelto la integral ya tenemos
que esta área es un tercio y como está
bajo el eje de las x entonces va a ser
menos un tercio y ya con esto hemos
terminado este ejercicio y de hecho como
todavía tengo un poco de tiempo quiero
enseñarles a ustedes cómo se resuelve
por la inversa de la regla de la cadena
es decir cómo hacer esto por la regla de
la cadena entonces déjenla borrar un
poco nuestro espacio entonces voy a
borrar todo esto que tenemos aquí
vamos a borrarlo y a continuación lo que
voy a hacer es utilizar la fórmula que
sabemos de la derivada por la regla de
la cadena para resolver esta integral
entonces bueno aquí tengo esta integral
bueno esta integral del principio no me
sirve mucho lo voy a ver mejor como ya
lo habíamos visto en la segunda integral
entonces aquí tengo la derivada del
coseno de x que es el menos seno de x y
aquí tengo una función llamada coseno de
x entonces utilizando la regla de la
cadena lo voy a escribir de una manera
distinta
voy a poner que esto es igual
y ahora si tengo yo el coseno elevado al
cuadrado hay que sumarle 1 el exponente
entonces me queda coseno elevado al cubo
entre 3 y esto evaluado de medios a pi y
darse cuenta de una cosa yo ya tengo el
resultado de una manera muy sencilla
porque yo tengo al lado la derivada del
coseno que es el menos seno de x
entonces si yo dijera por ejemplo que el
coche no es u y yo tengo una variable o
más bien una función elevada al cuadrado
de al lado su derivada entonces lo que
tengo que hacer es sumarle 1 el
exponente de esta función y dividirlo
entre el exponente y ahora sí resolver
esto solamente se hacen los límites de
integración esto es lo mismo que el
coseno de pi elevado al cubo entre 3 ya
esto hay que quitarle lo del límite
inferior es decir el seno de pi medios
elevado al cubo entre 3 y si hacemos las
operaciones correspondientes esto me va
a quedar menos un tercio menos 0
entonces simple sencillamente me queda
menos un tercio y ya está ya pues tengo
el resultado de la integral hecha por la
regla de la cadena espero que desee ha
sido muy útil y nos vemos en el
siguiente
vídeo